[Music]
keep before your eyes day by day
death and exile and everything that
seems terrible but most of all death
and then you will never have any abject
thought nor will you yearn for anything
beyond measure
in chapter 21 epictetus is suggesting to
us
an old stoic practice one that's not
confined solely to the stoics but
which they made considerable use of
which is
bringing before the eyes or what we
nowadays call
visualization you notice that
visualization
basically means the same thing we're
talking about vision
vision is through your eyes bringing
something before your eyes
so what are we supposed to visualize and
how is this supposed to benefit us he
talks about visualizing things that
we tend to view as a culture
and as individuals as terrible things as
calamities so he says keep before your
eyes
day by day death
and exile fugay and we'll talk a little
bit more about that in a moment
and everything that seems terrible but
most of
all death and then you will never have
any abject thought
nor will you earn for anything beyond
measure now this is a very short passage
but it's very rich
and there's a lot to unpack here so
death itself notice the the emphasis
that he gives to that death
ends the whole show for us right
there's nothing more happening there's
there's no more choosing
there's no more working upon yourself
there's no more feeling good there's no
more feeling bad
after death comes and so if we remind
ourselves of
what later philosophers have called the
finitude of human existence
that is going to really help us put
matters into perspective
epictetus has a really interesting
passage in the discourses
where he says you know if if i find out
that i'm going to die this is roughly
paraphrasing
i would just keep on doing what i'm
doing because i should be doing this
anyway right if you you know somebody
comes to you and says oh you're going to
die tomorrow
and then suddenly you totally change
your life that's a sign that your life
has been
mislived and poorly oriented
and badly prioritized up until that
point
sometimes people really need a
near-death
experience or the you know
clear horizon being said you've got six
months to live
in order for this to kick in the stoics
thought that we ought to engage
in you know thinking about death you
know uh
and visualizing what could happen
or what inevitably will happen uh
throughout our life and that it's not
done for a morbid purpose it's not done
to make us
feel bad it's actually done in order to
liberate us by allowing us to see
what's what really matters and what's
kind of trivial
you know you see him giving lots of
examples of not being too upset
when for example a child or a spouse
dies
but another way of looking at this is
that
it's to recognize the finitude how
valuable the time that we actually do
have together
is and that we should try to avoid
screwing it up with all of our
worries and conflicts and concerns and
all of that sort of business so keep
before your eyes day by day now notice
what he's saying there day by day
it's not something that you do once and
for all and then never think about it
it's something that you do as a daily
practice
you could do this in the morning you
could do this at night you could think
to yourself well
uh how was the day this might be the
last one i get
i might not wake up from this and not
doing that in any sort of
maudlin way but recognizing that that's
that's actually
the case now he talks also about exile
fugay and exile was something that
epictetus knew something about
he himself had to go into exile
because when he was teaching as a
philosopher in rome
the roman emperor at the time decided
hey these philosophers have to go i'm
kicking them out
he relocated not somewhere else in italy
but all the way back to the greek
speaking world
which is where uh aryan wrote down these
these
discourses that that form the end
caridian
so he knew something about having to
leave it all behind you know when when
you have to go into exile
you're not going to get top dollar for
your stuff you're going to
leave sometimes with just the proverbial
shirt on your back and hopefully some
sandals on your feet
and if you're lucky some food in the bag
and that means that you become dependent
upon other people if you don't have
family or friends
then upon strangers and whether they'll
help you out or not
you know refugees are an example of
people who are forced into
exile you know we have many refugees in
our world today
and you see the sorts of travails that
they go through
people don't choose to become refugees
very lightly it has to get quite bad for
them to say i'm i'm leaving here
sometimes their homes are destroyed
sometimes their families have been
decimated
sometimes they're being threatened with
torture
and rape and then murder after that
so this is a terrible thing
this is something that you know we can
look at and say
uh nobody should have that inflicted
upon them
and then we can wonder about how we
would ourselves
deal with that sort of situation how
would we deal uh with other
things that as epictetus says um
seem terrible right dana in greek
fearsome the things that provoke a great
amount of
fear in us not just things that provoke
a certain amount of fear phobos
but the things that seem like they would
destroy our world
what else would fit into this category
well for some people losing their job
you know many people here in in our
country in america
are as economists have shown
effectively two paychecks away from
losing much of what they have not being
able to make house payments not being
able to make car payments
not being able to pay the bills not
being able to pay debts that they
they have and so it you know we live in
fairly precarious times
and these are times that are more
similar to what it was like back
in ancient greece and rome i think for
many people
um relationships oftentimes people
feel that if a certain relationship is
to founder
or god forbid that person should pull
their affection away
like the entire world would fall apart
other people see
social uh status as a
good that is intensely vulnerable
in that way what if people find out that
i'm not really this is what's called the
imposter syndrome
what if people find out that i'm not
really what i pretend to be
you know i'm not as competent will they
will they take my position away will
people look at me differently
what if people find out that i don't
know as much as i
i claim to know or even just people
think that i know
what if people find out i'm not a great
musician i'm not a great athlete
go on and on and on and on and it's
often very successful people people who
have
lots of talents who suffer from this
imposter syndrome
these are worries that people have so
one way of dealing with this
is to like epictetus says visualize for
yourself
what's the worst that could happen and
then along with this
what could i do if that happens to me
so what is indeed the worst that could
happen with respect to a relationship
with respect to somebody who you love
dying with respect to
the election coming up with respect
people are getting very worked up about
that
uh with respect to your professional
career
what are or what what is the worst that
could happen if you get an f in a class
visualize these things daily
and then if they happen which they
probably won't
you're going to actually be equipped
you'll have things in perspective
and be able to handle them you'll have
more emotional resiliency as they say
and he says you'll never have any abject
thought nor will you yearn for anything
beyond measure
you're not going to have these these
dejected
depressive thoughts uh or panicking that
don't allow people to deal with
the the things that happen to them
but it's also going to help you to
maintain perspective
about what really is worth desiring
or being averse to what is worth
choosing and pursuing
and what is worth uh choosing against
and and trying to reject away from
yourself
all of this can be a very helpful
daily practice to do and this is indeed
what many stoics
have done and still do today
if you yearn for philosophy prepare it
once to be met with ridicule to have
many people jeer at you and say
here he is again turned philosopher all
of a sudden
and where do you suppose you got that
high brow
but do you not put on a highbrow and do
you
so hold fast to the things which to you
seem best
as a man who has been assigned by god to
this post
and remember that if you abide by the
same principles
those who formerly used to laugh at you
will later come to admire you
but if you are worsted by them you will
get the laugh
on yourself twice
this chapter number 22 is kind of near
and dear to my heart because it reminds
me of you know when i first started
studying philosophy
and did not follow epictetus advice
and i've seen many other people do this
as well
now epictetus says if you yearn for
philosophy if if that's
what you desire epithumase if you have a
hankering a an appetite for philosophy
prepare it once to be met with ridicule
and that is probably just
as true in our day as it was
in epictetus day it's kind of funny
because
you know a lot of people will idealize
certain time periods as if those were
you know when
everybody was an intellectual and and
you know thought
studying philosophy was cool philosophy
has never really been cool
it's always been something that some
people
have had negative things to say about
and like he says ridicule and he's got
this very
long long word here catego menos right
greek is great for being able to compose
words and epictetus
throws out a doozy right there it means
something like
not just people are gonna you know
snicker at you they're gonna really make
fun of you they're gonna say
look at that guy who's doing philosophy
or look at that girl who thinks she's so
smart
this is common this is something that
socrates faced
if you read some of the platonic
dialogues you will see
younger people saying to socrates what
the hell's wrong with you you know
philosophy that sort of stuff is fine
for kids
but once you become a grown man now you
got to get
serious about stuff find yourself a
profession get into politics
do something that's real not this airy
nonsense
you know with your head up in the clouds
um
people have been saying this sort of
thing for a long time even the people
who sometimes
claim that they're interested in
philosophy or that they respect it
may often harbor a kind of you know
secret envy or resentment or
any of those sort of things and it's
easy to to laugh at people
so he says um be prepared to have many
people jeer at you
and say here he is again turn
philosopher all of a sudden
you know and it makes sense if you're
just starting out you're making a change
in your life
it's this way not just with philosophy
but with any sort
of important life conversion so you know
you go on a diet
and people are like oh yeah you're going
to lose weight yeah well i'll believe it
when i see it
you know you have some sort of religious
conversion or a conversion away from
religion or people and people are like
yeah that's not really going to stick
you think all that stuff right now
even relationships you know you get
involved with somebody romantically and
people are like oh yeah look at this guy
now he's a poet he's in love you know
give it a couple weeks
you know people are always going to be
cynical at least a certain proportion
of them and why shouldn't they be i mean
we've seen plenty of people who jump
into things and they don't really stick
with it
that is a common human experience
one that we ourselves have had one that
we've seen many other people have
lots of people say they're going to
study philosophy how many of them
actually do stick with it
you can find this out by looking at
youtube video
playlists first video in the playlist
of some philosophy thing you know
hundreds of thousands of views
it tapers off after that maybe you get
down to the last video in the playlist
and there's only a thousand views
that means that a thousand people
actually stuck with that video series
that's not yet even like doing
philosophy that's just
hearing somebody else talk about
philosophy and maybe thinking about it
yourself
but 100 000 people petered out
along the way it's like that with with
anything that requires real
uh persistence so he says um
where do you suppose you got that high
brow you know when we talk about
highbrow
we're talking about you know we're
another word where is that egghead
coming from
oh your head is so stuffed with
knowledge right and
epictetus says don't put on a highbrow
don't don't put on airs that you're
smarter
than anyone else when you first start
out doing stoic philosophy
you're probably going to have a hell of
a time with confusions
saying oh i'm so badly off i don't know
what i'm doing
i keep on failing and i don't even
understand these passages
here uh you know and i i'm looking at
this to try to help me and
i mean i'm laughing a little bit at this
but i'm laughing at my
my own experiences with this myself
because i've gone through that
not just with stoic philosophy but with
a few others
it's tough it's it's difficult and so
don't
set your up yourself up for
the kinds of you know ridicule that
you'll come in for which might lead you
to failure if you're not already
well situated at the beginning you've
got to in certain ways take it easy
on yourself by not presenting a a
target for ridicule to other people so
he says
do you so hold fast to the things which
to you
seem best as a man who has been assigned
by god to this post and remember that if
you abide by the same principles
something's going to happen now this
abiding by these principles this
being assigned by god to the post that
is coming from the
the god to the post thing is socrates
right socrates is a great ideal for
for the stoics in general and especially
for epictetus
socrates thought that doing philosophy
and he wasn't just teaching philosophy
he was doing philosophy
he was engaged in inquiry was something
that
was a mission from god that he had been
assigned this mission
the way in which he arrived at that's a
little bit you know strange
but you know that that's a whole
different conversation
if you're going to be doing philosophy
according to epictetus that's something
that's coming from whatever you want to
call it the transcendent right
and stick with it act as if that's been
your assignment your duty that you're on
the roster right
and he says hold fast to the things
which you to seem
to you seem best if it seems like you
if it seems best to you that putting
stoic philosophy into practice
that trying it out is really good for
you
do it you don't have to talk about it
with other people you don't have to make
a show of it
you definitely don't have to grow a
philosopher's beard
that was kind of a common thing back
then or dress in a certain way
you don't have to have any philosophy
swag and these days like a ball cap
or a t-shirt i love epictetus you know
any of that sort of stuff
um you don't have to you know try to
look profound and
carrying around a book all the time of
epictetus
those are just externals it's in here
and in here that you know
your philosophy is gradually being
digested being assimilated being made
part of as epictetus says your sinews
and your muscles
so do that and then what will happen
afterwards he says
if you abide by these same principles
those who formerly used to laugh at you
will later come to admire you
if you can stick with it then you can be
a philosopher
but you have to stick with it if you
don't stick with it if you do it
halfway if you do it just on weekends
if you do it only when somebody's
watching
then it's never really going to become
part of who you are
and you're going to fail at it and
you're going to fail anyway to some
degree but you're going to fail in ways
that make other people look at you and
say
silly philosopher that's what philosophy
is it's that stupid stuff that that guy
does
he says if you um uh
are worsted by the these you know
principles and these people you will get
the laugh
on yourself twice if you're gonna do
philosophy
do it in a non-showy way and stick with
it
and you know by the time that people
start saying oh hey
you really are doing philosophy well uh
this is something i find attractive
you're probably not even going to care
that much
about what other people think because
the stoic philosophy will be working for
you
so this is some great advice and i think
this is great advice
not only for anybody who wants to
practice stoic philosophy
but for anybody who wants to get into
philosophy in general
if it should ever happen to you that you
turn to externals with a view to
pleasing someone
rest assured that you have lost your
plan of life
be content therefore in everything to be
a philosopher
and if you wish also to be taken for one
show to yourself that you
are one and you will be able to
accomplish it
chapter 23 also has a nice observation
about
doing philosophy and being taken for a
philosopher
but this applies to just about anything
else that we want to be
serious about he says if it should ever
happen to you that you
turn to externals with a view to
pleasing someone
rest assured you've lost your plan of
life
now unless you maybe your plan of life
was to try to please people
or to you know focus on externals
but that's a self-defeating way of
approaching things according to the
stoics
anytime that you are placing yourself
and your thoughts your opinions your
feelings your desires your aversions
into the hands of another you're taking
a huge risk
now even if they are good people that
you're doing this with they can screw up
they can they can mistake what's going
on
you can end up being hurt and if you do
end up being hurt you're the one who
placed
all that in the hands of another if if
it's about you know the more con
you know common situations where you're
trying to win approval
or you're trying to as you know we say
these days be a people pleaser
in many cases you can never get that or
what you're going to get is going to be
so much
less than what you are actually desiring
that you're just not going to be happy
with it or it'll come at the wrong time
we can go on and on and on with all
sorts of modalities of this
but now notice what he's connecting
together here two different things
he's talking about external things
the the exo right and now he's also
talking about pleasing
other people with having that literally
as your your plan what it is that you're
you're intending you know uh prosta
bules
you know uh with the intention in mind
of making somebody else
happy about it or pleasing them
gratifying them would be another way of
saying it
if you're doing this you're
putting you're putting things at risk in
two different ways external things
by themselves are by their nature
not subject to our our power
and so you may have all sorts of desires
hopes fears
choices about them but you can't make
them go your way
other people who actually technically
are speaking
you know technically speaking are in the
class of external things
but here we think about like property or
reputation
other people other people who can make
choices
other people who are free other people
who have their own
motivational structures their own
desires their own opinions their own
thoughts
also out of your control now you're
mixing together
two things that are totally out of your
control
so let's say you actually do manage to
succeed with the external thing you make
a ton of money
because you're trying to please your dad
who always said that you were never
going to be a success right
so you do make a ton of money you
succeed in that
odds are you know most people won't do
that but you do it
your dad can still say oh yeah you made
a ton of money you're still a failure
i i i'm not going to give you my
approval
you can get the best grades and
the school can turn you down and say oh
we're not really interested in somebody
with your life experiences
you can win a prize you can
get the top position in something you
can write the best book in the world
and the people whose approval you care
about can still
say i'm not interested don't really care
you're still a loser you know
if you are going to place your eggs into
this basket
it's really a bad choice it's really
dangerous
there's no way in which you can possibly
make sure
that things are going to go your way the
way that you want them to go
and so he says be assured you have lost
your plan of life you have in
another way of saying it you've actually
destroyed apolasis
pain and and stasi you're the the
you know the way in which you've
structured things
now he's talking about stoic philosophy
there and the fact
that we cannot invest ourselves
in trying to succeed in external ways to
please
other people because we're just you know
setting ourselves up for failure
and we're not going to concentrate on
the things that are within us
we're not going to concentrate on our
own structure of desire and whether it's
screwed up
or whether it's on track we're not going
to
examine our thoughts and beliefs and
opinions
to see whether they're nuts or partly
nuts
or semi-rational or
on the way to being rational i mean
here's here's something you can take for
granted
whatever assemblage of thoughts you've
got in your head
at any given time some of them are not
rational yet
and that's that's uh sort of a basic
for the stoic uh practice
they may seem rational and the process
of following them out
is a rational process but you can have
all sorts of irrational assumptions
now if you're focused on you know
succeeding in external things so you can
please these people
you're not going to focus on that as a
matter of fact in order to
to get those things you might have to
put into your head
all sorts of irrational thoughts that
allow you to have the motivation
to go out there and make a million bucks
or to win political office
or to you know uh write write a book
that somehow you know ends up being
being on the bestseller list or doing
this or doing this or doing this
but it's not good overall even though
that seems to be an external good
it's not good for you to have false
thoughts in your head
to have irrational thought processes so
he goes on and he says
how do we apply this to philosophy be
content therefore
in everything to be a philosopher
to be a philosopher and if you wish also
to be taken for one
show to yourself that you are one and
you will be able to accomplish it
if you want other people to recognize
how smart a person you are how well put
together you
are how you know uh straight
straight and narrow your life is or how
rich it is
or how you're just you know great in all
these ways
first you actually have to convince
yourself of that and this is
another good point it's a little bit of
a digression
why do we try to please others so much
it's because we're not pleased with
ourselves
we want that approval from other people
for whatever external achievements or
you know goods or or resources we're
able to provide them
give them a lot of gifts right oh
they're going to love me if i give them
gifts
no they might despise you and think that
you're kind of a patsy
for giving them gifts you don't control
any of this
you do control what's here if you want
to be a philosopher
in the sense of somebody who practices
stoic philosophy that is
up to you it's going to take some work
you can't snap your fingers and
automatically do it because
trust me if you could i would have done
it years ago
but you can work at it and you can get
yourself to the point where you can
recognize the progress that you're
making and then you're no longer
dependent
on those other people out there and you
see there's kind of a self-reinforcement
here
that's what stoic philosophy is about
that's what it's teaching us
as a good thing not being dependent upon
other people not being hindered by them
not being negatively affected by them
being who we are and working upon
ourselves
so like he says be a philosopher don't
worry about whether other people think
you're a philosopher
or if you're going to worry about what
this person thinks
who what you think about yourself and if
you can convince yourself
then let them know that you're a
philosopher but until then keep it under
wraps
[Music]
you